Now, let's look at an example with multiple regression in
our studio.
I have two examples here. Let me begin with the simpler one.
So you become familiar with this intact and
then I'll show you the more advanced one.
What we want to do.
Is plot a relationship?
between two
let's say data sets.
Okay, so we will create two vectors.
two vectors one-dimensional matrices
and then
use the
the modeling capability of our studio
to see if
we can find some.
correlation covariance
between these two
Vectors so these vectors will effectively
be our random variables.
Okay. So let's say we have two random variables one will
be for height.
This is how you assign a value to a variable. This is
your variable and this is the assignment.
syntax
And if you want to create a vector you say you type in
the C function and then you plug in your data points. So we have two.
Sets of data height and weight. We imagine
these to be our random variables one random variable containing
the heights of
people
and this particular example has to do with chess team.
So these are the Heights and weights of players on a chesty.
chess team
players
let's to plot these on a
simple XY axis use the plot function from
our studio now that it takes on many different
arguments.
What kind of plot colors?
The data points you want to plot but here's
a simple example.
You begin as you can see here. It's indicating to me
the arguments that you can pass to this function.
The first argument you pass will
be what goes on to the x-axis?
The other one obviously what goes onto the y-axis so
for X we will put a height.
and for why we will have
wait
Now, we also want to label our graph our XY graph.
To do that you have the third argument called xlab.
And you can type in whatever you want here. But this will be the
height of students or Heights of the players in meters.
and for the y-axis
We will label it as well Waits.
and kilograms
now if you're from North America, and you're
not familiar with these
units of measurement
I mean, this is the best unit of measurement. I don't know why they
would use something like
what do you call? What do you have you have powers?
and
feet and inches
so much more accurate to use the empirical system. But
anyway.
So we label our x-axis will label our
white access. And if you just want to give your plot a name in general,
there is the other argument called Main.
And we can say chess team.
Okay.
Now, let's see what we have after this point in our
studio. There is no run.
You don't want to plus run because it runs the entire script. What
we want to do rather is.
like
process these variables
plotted see what the product looks like and then
continue with the remaining fast to do that. You click on the
line that what you want to that you want to process. So we
want to process line number two. So you click there and then
you click on on Mac. It's
command error. It's on Windows. I think it should be controlled enter.
But if you do it correctly, you can see that now this
variable has been stored in the environment.
Again, we will do the same for the weight.
So we now have these two vectors.
And the memory of the computer now we
will use the plot function built into our studio.
to well plot these
okay.
And we can see here as the heights of the players increase
so there's the weight.
It makes sense. You know, the bigger you are the more you will wait.
on average
so before I move on to the next line of code these
These circles remember from this side I showed these
are the observed values.
Like these are actually people actually people.
like this data point
that someone of who is 1.6 meters tall
and
you know about
51 52 kilograms
That's one an actual person who was measured.
So is this one?
This person I think is about one seventy. I
think it's 174.
That will be five foot eight.
five foot eight inches and 80 kilograms
which is about
I think 180 pounds.
So these are actual people now what we want to do is fit a
line.
If the line fits properly like if it goes if
it goes through this Center.
Or let me say if it goes like it.
if it
like it follows through because we could if you
look at it carefully you kind of see a pattern right? Like there
is a linear relationship between a person's height and
their weight the totally you are the more you wait. Now, we know this of
course it's common sense.
But visually if you look at it, you can
kind of see there's a pattern though more you
the taller you are the more you away.
What we wanted to do is get the the regression
line to go through it.
So we can really make it obvious that there is in fact
a linear relationship between the height of
a person and the weight of a person.
So we've plotted.
The height of the weights of these people and we can see that there
is in fact, there's a pattern emerging. Let's draw a
line to draw a line through it.
There's a function called LM.
linear model
and if I if you open the first parenthesis, you will
see the arguments that you can pass.
to the linear model the first argument
Is the formula?
Then you have their data points.
Substance of that data if you want.
But let's let's look at a simple example and it will
explore the other arguments.
in a subsequent example
so we want to say
that
the weight
random variable
is a function of
the height random variable
now
quick note about this syntax this tilty.
This till day doesn't have
to do with normal distributions and tax. Okay, so
wait here is the dependent
variable.
Height is the independent variable for this particular model.
Okay.
If we had other coefficients.
or other
dependent variables you would append them with plus so you can
have weight age. Let's say salary, whatever.
Okay.
So why this would be like your y equals and then?
your regression model